-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-I'm so happy you're here.
-I am, too.
It's nice to be here.
-This audio memoir is wonderful.
And one of the great thing
about it is,
there are certain songs that
as a listener,
you become so comfortable
with it, you forget,
at some point,
they weren't songs,
and someone had to write them.
And you talk about writing
"Carolina in My Mind."
And it's really
just a wonderful story.
-Well, yeah, we had hoped people
would be interested in that.
And it was.
You know, I can't remember
an awful lot of the particular
of writing
some of those older songs.
But I do remember "Carolina.
-Yeah.
And it was -- Can you share with
us some of how it came about
-Well, yeah, when I
was recording my first album
I was the first person signed to
the Beatles' new record label,
Apple Records.
And they had --
-Can I just stop real quick?
Like --
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I imagine anyone,
when they sign their first
record deal, there's a lot
of pressure behind it.
But when it's the Beatles --
I mean, that seems like
there'd be even more pressure.
-Well, I don't --
[ Laughter ]
No, it felt --
it felt very easy.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, okay. Okay.
-No, it did.
There was very little sort of --
And that may have been
the problem
with Apple Records, actually
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That it was pretty much
hemorrhaging money.
[ Laughter ]
But while that window
of opportunity was open, I -
it was a great thing for myself,
Mary Hopkins, Jackie Lomax
Billy Preston, you know.
-Yeah, of course.
-And a number of other
lucky acts who were --
You know,
but it was only a year or so
that the label still had other
non-Beatle performers on it.
But, anyway, we were --
we were --
-I imagine that was a weir
meeting day where they said,
"You know what? I think we'r
just gonna be the Beatles.
[ Laughter ]
"We think our record label
should just be the Beatles
for here on out."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, a guy named Allen Klein
who was actually, I think,
a New Yorker convinced,
I think, John and Yoko
that he'd be a good manage
for the Beatles.
This is after
Brian Epstein died.
And Allen Klein
basically threw everybody
off the record label
is what happened.
-But you worked on this song
with the --
It wasn't just the label.
You actually went and brought it
to the Beatles and worked on i
with some of the Beatles.
-With that particular song
well, it was --
I wrote it
while we were recording.
We took a break.
Well, that is to say,
the Beatles took a break, so
the studio that they were using,
when they weren't there,
I was there.
I would sort of scamper in
there, you know,
and put down a few
of my little tracks
and then clear out
before they came back.
[ Laughter ]
But I got to hang around
a little bit, too.
It was great.
[ Laughter ]
-In the moment, did you know -
I mean, you know,
did you know it was great?
Or was it one of those --
"Okay, yeah, okay, good"?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-"I'm glad to hear that."
-Yeah, I knew it --
I knew it was extraordinar
and exceptional,
and I couldn't believe it.
But they took a break.
So they basically
closed the studio down.
And I went to an island
in the Mediterranean
off the coast of Spain,
called Formentera.
Formentera.
And while I was there --
in those days, it was an
extremely sort of laid-bac
and primitive place.
There were no -- There reall
were no cars on the island
And people got around
on bicycles or on their feet
And I just -- I met --
I met some wonderful peopl
while I was there
and had some adventures.
But myself --
[ Laughter ]
Myself -- excellent.
But myself and a girl name
Karen from Sweden, we --
we went to -- we went to
a neighboring island.
There was a ferry service
over there.
We went over to see
what was happening
on the island of Ibiza.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And while we were there,
we went to --
I can't remember if it was
a wedding or a funeral.
But we went to some sort of a --
[ Laughter ]
But it was some kind of
congregation of people.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-People seemed like they wer
in a good mood.
-So probably wedding.
-Yeah, well, possibly,
but, you know?
-Yeah, you never know.
Could've been a bad guy.
Yeah.
-But we --
You know, we had intended
to take the ferry back ove
to Formentera by, you know
the evening, by the last boat,
but we missed the last boat.
We had -- We had our tickets
but we had no money.
So there was no -- no plac
to get a room or any shelter
We just stayed on the streets.
And there was a cafe that
was closed down for the night.
And the tables were up -- th
chairs were up on the tables
you know, like they are.
And we just took a couple
of those chairs down
and sat at the table
for hours and hours
while the night went by.
And I started getting homesick
And I thought of this song
and my home so far away
and wrote "Carolina in My Mind
as the sun was coming up.
But we're not gonna
play that song tonight.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So I'll introduce the son
that we will play tonight
the next time I'm here.
-Oh, that'd be great, yeah
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
-And then we'll cut it togethe
for the rerun. Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Your album -- these are
old standards you're playing
These are the songs that,
when you were coming up
and playing music, folk music --
the music that was more modern
This is the music
your parents listened to.
Did you like the music
your parents listened to
when you were young?
-You know, I did -- I did.
Certainly, when I was a kid,
I loved that music.
I got an attitude about it
when I was sort of
a teenage musician, myself
But, you know, I --
these songs taught me a lot.
-Yeah.
-Just learning to play the
on the guitar as a kid
taught me the changes
and taught me a lot
about harmonies.
And just there's a wealth
of information there.
And, you know, it seems likely
to me that this is --
Well, I know it's the case tha
Bob Dylan and Paul McCartney
and Paul Simon and the entir
generation of songwriters
that I come from was also
informed by this same music,
these standards.
You know?
-We're so excited you're gonna
play one for us tonight.
And it is just always such
a delight to have you here
Thank you so much.
James Taylor.